on arrive maintenant la séquence travail
à domicile avec cet appareil fantastique
qui est un ampex appareils de
professionnels ce n'est pas fantastique
cela me paraît très simple
au mirail et j'ai étudié ces gestes des
gestes de ses chansons
je me souviens je n'ai pu très bien il
ya exactement ce que vous faisiez avant
de chanter à avignon avec papa maman et
de toute la famille c'était si l'essai
d'après les reportages que nous avons il
fallait pas que je crois c'était dans le
quartier des oiseaux la croix des
oiseaux
depuis les parents maintenant son parti
d'avoir des oiseaux belle maison qui
leur plaît beaucoup aux attentes mais
toujours en avignon toujours à la ligne
vous avez un petit peu pris le rôle de
tuteur puisque vous passez dans le temps
avec des rimes et sa famille vit avec sa
tante la soeur
si vous êtes le personnage disant le
plus critiqué le plus envié aussi dans
ce métier quand on parle de jeu ni stark
et puis en plus est un métier qui ne
vous êtes pas vous avez une fâcheuse
vous avez métier la presse à rio cette
année avec une fâcheuse réputation ça
exact bon alors d'après monsieur d'être
la fois monsieur de tyran quand c'est
pas vrai c'est pas vrai parce qu'on
n'est pas johnny tout le monde dit ça
mais c'est pas vrai c'est à dire parce
qu'il nous apporte le nice marque des
tout parce que sans que jeunechamp
serait pas poursuit maintenant via la
société mirail d'associer non moi je
n'en ai dit mireille on employés 28
l'employé ben finalement toute façon
vous avez prouvé mirail que vous aviez
quelque chose puisque je pense qu'il n'y
a pas de miracle mais il est d'autres
filles dans ce métier qui avait aussi
quelque chose et qui n'ont pas réussi
comme vous donc malgré tout et c'est à
vous de nice tard il y a quand même vous
allez faire un travail
oui je fais un travail mais n'oubliez
pas une chose il ya d'autres filles
d'autres garçons comme vous dites que
nous allons sur les qualités mais
mireille avant tout d'abord avant tout
une chose c'est une travailleuse elle
fait son métier elle travaille en
professionnel dès maintenant vous êtes
une personne et exotique elle appelé les
quelques 20 ans
est ce que vous avez pensé vous y avez
pensé parce que vous ferez dans 5 ans 6
ans
j'espère chanter bon et après après je
voudrais murray plus enchanté
l'impression qu'il vit un petit peu
quand même comme une pensionnaire c'est
à dire que par exemple est ce que vous
connaissez les grands magasins oui
jusqu'au bout vous avez été souvent paso
ben non donc le cinéma
messi ne m'a pas sauvé mais plus tard je
me rattraperai plus tard nous parions si
les maris tout c'est que mireille et
c'est à travers l'appareil et les
problèmes défi où tous les grands tous
les grands fils enfin pour les remplacer
qu'elle avait pas mal
enfin c'est quand même type est
inquiétant parce que vous ne faites pas
uniquement un passant disons que tony
stark dans votre tante
vous êtes vraiment vous avez des
horaires très précis très établie c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire métier ce
métier autrement peut pas le faire
autrement si c'est pas réglée six
moutons sur le soir d'abord j'aime pas
sortir le soir
moi j'aime bien ça nous sommes sans rien
du tout